the big news out of the market on sunday
night which we didn't get to talk about
yesterday was square is buying after pay
now square is uh currently
on sofi it is the only stock that i own
on the sofi application why because i
like square that's my personal opinion i
like square i think jack dorsey is a
really good ceo
and i tend to think that square's got a
pretty unique
business model product etc now square is
buying after
pay and the reason why they're buying it
for
29 billion dollars is because
they have younger users in the consumer
lending space
now this deal which is supposed to close
kind of q1 of next year
has a number of unique aspects to it
that
if the integration goes well and if the
combination of these two businesses
works out the way that square and after
pay believe it will
it will create a very very
interesting business for square to
continue to expand globally
and into other demographics so square
said the buy now pay later concept
represents a chance to capitalize on a
shift
away from traditional credit especially
among younger consumers
jack dorsey's exact quote was we have
built our business to make the financial
system more fair accessible and
inclusive
and after pay has built a trusted brand
aligned with those principles obviously
jack dorsey a very principled person
who seems to constantly seek folks that
he can partner with whether internally
externally or
through acquisitions that have those
same principles around financial
fairness accessibility and inclusiveness
it's also why he's such a big fan of
bitcoin
jack dorsey then went on to also say
quote
together we can better connect our cash
app and seller ecosystems to deliver
even more compelling products and
services for merchants and consumers
putting the power back in their hands
now these are all
really big nice words they put together
jack is a very articulate person so what
exactly does this
mean it means that square is going to
integrate after pay
into both its consumer cash app and its
seller product for small businesses
according to the cfo
and square recently launched banking
operations including checking and
savings accounts for small businesses
and they offer loans after pay was
founded in 2015
it launched in america in 2018 and now
that we're watching square buy it for 29
billion dollars you would say wow that's
a very big
impressive valuable business square
isn't just buying it though with cash
square's doing an all stock deal which
means that
uh shareholders of square this is a bet
the company type decision
the dilution here is i don't know 20 25
whatever the math works out to in terms
of squares current market share and a 29
billion
all stock deal so square really really
really believes that after pay plus
square equals
winning in the future this is the
largest acquisition ever by square
after pay has 16 million users cash app
has 70 million
annual users and square just reported
a q2 profit of 1.1 billion dollars which
is up 91
year-over-year so cash app continues to
explode in popularity the financial
uh performance of that specific part of
square's business continues to perform
really well almost doubling
year over year and they saw an increase
in gross payment volume of 88
to over 42 billion dollars as well so
joe and john when we think of
after pay and this acquisition one do we
agree this is a bet the company moment
for square
yeah i mean they they're spending what
almost 30 billion dollars like
that's an absurd amount of money like
well they're not spending it they're
technically using stock yeah right which
is
spending it to a degree just different
acquiring a company yeah for 30 billion
the other part of this to me is after
pay is
only offered by a hundred thousand
retailers so you know what i thought was
interesting when we were looking at this
earlier was
uh everyone's referring them as an
australian company and talking about how
cash app is gonna have access to these
markets in australia and all this stuff
but i read that fifty percent of the
underlying sales on the platform are
actually done in the u.s
so most of their retailers are in
australia but most of their volume comes
from the us
well u.s is big dog of course but the
integration with cash app will obviously
help expand that here so if they're
already growing at 150
per year it's only going to accelerate
yeah the
i don't know if we have the number maybe
we can find it real quick in terms of
how many
retailers square has but it's definitely
more than a hundred thousand
and so if you basically take after pays
business uh and the product they have
you then immediately put that in the
hands of 70 million cash app users you
put it in the hands of
uh however many probably million plus uh
retailers that square has
2 million merchants 2 million that's
pretty good guess on my part uh
2 million merchants then you can
effectively say 100k got you to a 29
billion
valuation if you roll it out to 2
million maybe you don't simply get a 20x
the value of the business
but could you 2 3 4 5x the business
absolutely right you're literally just
drastically increasing both the user
base and the merchant side of the
business
seems kind of like a no-brainer if
you're the after pay folks plus you also
got 30 billion
well those those two million are kind of
spread across different industries right
after pay and kind of the buy now pay
later system is really for large
purchase items
uh things that you can kind of pay down
over time with zero interest not like
for a cup of coffee well so these
companies are also introducing uh what
they're called like digital credit cards
so instead of you having to go sign up
if you're after pay signing up 15
20 000 different merchants in australia
they gave they're basically offering one
credit card uh digital credit card where
you go and you give the consumer the
optionality to
use their service at any platform right
so any merchant you can say hey buy with
this card it'll be
uh you know buy now pay later same
concept but you do it over a credit card
instead of signing up individual
merchants so that's probably how they'll
expand quicker but it's a matter of just
getting the businesses to accept it
i also saw square stock up big you know
big big dog over here
seeing the seeing the green you're
checking your portfolio yeah on sofa.com
earlier you were like i believe in in
square i like jack dorsey you see all
this stuff you're doing it because you
want to make money
well you're incentivized yeah that's how
it's called aligned incentives joe
charlie down two and a half percent
today yeah what was it up yesterday
all right well he's like yeah what was
it like five percent over the last five
days
okay but it was up ten percent yesterday
the reason why that's interesting
go ahead was it up ten percent yesterday
i'm not gonna get big a big number
yeah no here here's why it's important
is because if you do an all stock deal
and you pay 29 billion dollars but your
stock goes up 10
let's just say about 10 billion dollars
of value creation
you're really on a net basis or only
paying 19 billion dollar difference
for the business because the
announcement of the deal
ends up surging your stock right making
you more valuable and so there's a way
that you could back into some math where
they're not really paying the full 29.
what if they would have paid 20
premium on the stock price of after pay
instead of 30. they pay well
so i mean you can start to do all the
math right i think it was a 33
was it 30 or 33 something yeah 30
increase in the stock price from uh
friday's trading price
which means that it's obviously people
want to know if squares uh
you're roku
[Laughter]
i will not confirm nor deny but i will
say i only own
one public stock outside of gbtc now
square
that's it see if it gets you a 10 bagger
[Laughter]
yesterday i was posting uh videos on the
internet i did a little victory lap from
when i was on cnbc i liked your sweater
in the one yeah
when bitcoin's in the bear market you
got to wear the costume you got to play
their game when bitcoin's at forty
thousand dollars then they play your
game you read the t-shirt
yeah my my favorite meme that anyone
posted on the internet still today
is uh i went on cnbc a couple of months
ago maybe back in like march or april
when bitcoin's really raging like 50 60k
and somebody went back and got a picture
of me in a suit and tie
and uh then they put up a picture of me
then and they basically were like uh
when when uh you're in debt and bitcoins
down and the next one is when i'll buy
your [ __ ] country
[ __ ] was real funny um all right so we
got a chart on uh
on acquisitions here high margin
categories with higher acquisition costs
are more likely to subsidize
point of sale financing now when you
look at this
uh this is going back to what john was
talking about in terms of the different
industries we can basically see each
industry
has very different margins obviously
and also acquisition cost obviously and
so what this shows is that the size of
the bubble equals the average ticket
size
while seeking the financing in these uh
applications so the way that buy now pay
later
works is exactly how it sounds you can
buy now
and you pay for the product later
usually in monthly installments with
some sort of financing on the actual
application
uh if you look at the industries though
luxury
rental is really important fast fashion
which by the way i don't really know
what fast
fashion is but it sounds like it's fast
and it has something to do with clothes
uh which just kind of reminds me of like
quick service restaurants qsr
right i don't know what fast fashion
maybe john knows john's very very
fashionable we should do a breakdown on
qsr
one day yes but what's fascinating fast
fashion is the mass production of cheap
poor quality
disposable clothing sounds like
something you'd like
[Laughter]
i'm a fast fashion leader then it sounds
like you're a public wreck guy yeah yeah
public wreck
the industry turns out 80 billion
garments a year that's over 10 for every
person on earth
oh my god all right so fast fashion i
guess is clothes that you could throw
away it sounds like
yeah cheap clothes cheap clothes that
low quality that are supposed to be
disposed of
right and then we said okay uh just
making sure i didn't get that wrong
i don't know if it's we will do a
section on qsr as well john uh
luxury rental auto repair medical
cruise lines etc and what you can see is
like fast fashion is a perfect example
where the cost of customer acquisition
is very very high
but the gross margin that they make is
kind of middle of the road so fast
fashion is probably
not where they actually want to be
operating instead my guess is that they
want to be doing things around
entertainment and ticketing in the
bottom right here because the cost of
acquisition
is very low uh and then the gross margin
that they can make
is uh relatively high so you can kind of
work your way from entertainment
ticketing to medical all the way up to
luxury retail
uh is kind of where these folks want to
uh to exist
now australia after pays business is
concentrated in its home country with
49 of the business being in australia
and new zealand
which i love how new zealand just gets
thrown in with australia uh
you know two different places but we're
just going to throw them together and
then in north america we have 43 percent
and so you can kind of compare
uh these two uh locations the uk is only
eight percent
but seeing 49 in australia in new
zealand versus north america 43
and so here's the the chart right here
that is from a company report from the
first half
of fiscal year 2021. when we think about
this
does this give square is the benefit to
square that they get to go more global
or do we think the benefit really is
after pay gets more concentration
in the united states like how do you
guys think about the the uh
uh are we exporting cash app and square
services globally with this
are we more importing after pay pay now
uh
or buy now pay later importing importing
right i would agree with that yeah that
this is much more about bringing these
services to the united states to start
and then obviously square cash app uh
jack etc they want to bring squares
infrastructure a lot of the bitcoin
stuff they're doing
they want to bring it to places like
nigeria ghana uh other african countries
south america et cetera have you ever
used by now pay later
no i'd be p i'd be buying now paying now
sixty percent of consumers have used it
do you think it's kind of scheme or no
i mean look let's just have a little
conversation buy now pay later like what
are you buying that you can't pay now
for
right and if you look it's like luxury
goods fast fashion
right like you go on like the you know
like the shoe websites or stuff there
they all offer to hey zero down pay now
i think this gets at the point that
square is recognizing which is
is buy now pay laters popularity
rising at the same time that young
people's
interest in credit cards and traditional
credit is declining
so are you simply saying let's just use
an easy example let's say that 20
of the population of young people want
credit cards right historically and
that's
kind of where it's been is that
declining and by now pay later is
increasing but you're still just hitting
the 20 penetration yeah well so
uh i was reading about this earlier
mastercard jp morgan american express
city
all these traditional credit card
companies as you would think of them are
all offering these services now because
of that exact reason that traditional
credit cards are declining from that age
range and more people are just opting to
use the credit that's offered to them in
the uh
the buy now pay later system and i think
all those stocks went down when this was
announced
probably right because they all offer
similar services because really what
square is doing with this specific
acquisition is they're now positioning
themselves where one they can obviously
help on the seller ecosystem like the
businesses that are their partners
they can also now provide credit like
options
to consumers but it's not traditional
credit and so this squarely puts square
versus a visa or a mastercard
in terms of financial services but to
your point
there are a lot of people who say hey
using a credit card is really valuable
right
if you use a credit card the right way
like paid off every friday right john
then you end up actually getting in a
situation where the credit card can be a
huge benefit it's basically an
interest-free loan
yeah but if you use it incorrectly you
get saddled with debt
average americans got six thousand
dollars in in kind of a monthly
credit card build the average interest
rate that you pay on a credit card 16 17
you can get in a bad situation real fast
if you're not paying off the credit card
so the tool itself is not good or bad
how it's used and with what
level of severity then it becomes good
or bad same thing can be said about
buy now pay later right i don't know
what the average interest is that
somebody's paying on this stuff
but my guess is that it's lower than a
credit card so it's probably not 16 17
i could be wrong uh and if you use it
correctly
then it could actually be super valuable
if you're an idiot and you go
buy everything now and pay nothing later
then you end up just with a ton of debt
and you end up getting screwed right
yeah yeah i agree i mean i've never
bought anything on it so i don't know
how it worked like i'm assuming you
don't get anything you're a buy now pay
now guy
yeah yeah saying if you can't buy it
twice don't buy it yeah well twice if
you can't buy it with only a tenth of
what's in your bank account don't buy it
okay well that's relative but i mean
that's
that doesn't apply necessarily to
everything
you